quand j'étais petit j'étais fan de robin
des bois et quand je dis fans s'étaient
fans
aujourd'hui je voulais faire la cascade
impôts c'est très dangereux mais je vais
quand même le faire et un jour maurice
barthélémy des robins des bois m'appelle
si tu veux me rencontrer je t'ai fait
venir parce qu'en fait je voudrais te
proposer deux premiers rôles de mon film
c'est en fait un type un peu loser tu
vois ce que je veux dire sans trop de
personnalité quoi moche moche
ok faut que je travaille un peu le
personnage un travail de composition et
tous maintenant t'as rien à faire tu as
quitté le caire - au début le cinéma et
tout je pensais que sa lettre
comment les latino-américains janval est
arrivé sur le tournage c'est être comme
ça
bon finalement ça s'est passé un peu
différemment la question bonjour bonjour
je viens pour le film webb venu pour un
stage la sécu vous me direz ce crétin
l'annoncé pour le rôle le rôle des
médias
mais en fait c'est un tournant pour vous
disent rien donc le tournage a commencé
c'était le tournage si tu veux de plus
cool de la planète terre je serai
fermiers un peu ou pas un petit peu je
suis dans un endroit qui est le fantasme
de beaucoup de gens c'est à dire voilà
faire la moindre point et en fait je
peux pas parce qu'il faut une meuf
et mar
et
ça pulse - sa cause bah j'ai conduit
c'est pas le permis on s'en bat les
coups bas c'est une semaine décisive
dans le film donc il faut que ça soit
nickel genève et dont c'était bientôt
et tout d'un coup on apprend qu'il a
fait des phénomènes pas très normands
ont fait une dernière dans panel était
super jeu c'est mort
ouais
et surtout il garde la pêche toujours
tellement d'art pour correspondre aux
personnages on m'a demandé aussi de me
laisser pousser les cheveux
bon depuis j'aurais pu aller chez le
coiffeur mais j'ai oublié
en tout cas j'ai pu sortir une phrase
que je rêvais de devenir un jour à mes
cheveux non mais je laisse pousser pour
un rôle à sauf que malheureusement cette
phrase marche pas avec tout au mec tu
pue de la gueule à mon haleine non c'est
pour un rôle
vu les fous rires concept a fait pendant
certaines prises je pense qu'il y aura
une séquence bêtisier de 8h55
et bien en fait après très vite il a
senti que il avait des problèmes dans sa
vie il y avait notamment le truc sic
il y avait des toutes sortes de choses
en fait
il a commencé à les débloquer quand il
est pile et rentrer en france
bon j'ai insisté pour faire mes cascades
moi même un comme belmondo
au bout de cinq semaines le tournage
s'est terminé
évidemment il ya eu une petite émotion
hier bien fort je suis maurice
barthélémy et j'approuve ce message peut
paraître bête mais jouer tout simplement
remercier tous les gens qui peut-être
sans savoir m'ont permis de faire ce
film aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
internautes
les gens qui ont cliqué sur mes vidéos
qui les ont appréciés donc un grand
merci
vraiment je vais vous dire aussi merci
dans notre langue en allemand
guten tag donc le film s'intitule pas
très normal activités il sort le 30
janvier 2013 prochain dans tous les
cinémas normaux et tout de suite voici
la bande annonce officielle que vous
êtes le tout premier à voir
3 2 1 check it out
sans la crise
um c'est papa ça
c'est le nouvel et vise à 100
prendre tout un duo d'ici ce test
allez c'est pas trop
parce que ce bordel fille lui a fait
sarah khabibulin
quoi c'est l'humour de la cause alors je
suis pas de la creuse nantes maintenant
à wayne du coup c'est le moule devant
bolton huit mecs la métare aides
directes 20 minutes ça va être quand on
l'a retrouvée morte en bas des escaliers
s'accroître
j'adore le côté bourru débourou vous
présente karine bonjour bonjour j'ai
beaucoup de très bons choix soit une
pourriture comme il n'ya pas plus pourri
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie quoi
mais c'est quoi ça c'est de la merde
un croquis tutelle barak alors lâche
multitude continue là j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'ici stade et trouve pas
très normal de rameau non c'est juste on
dit pas très normand bonhomme a commencé
de stock
je suis une kalachnikov
bye
quoi